bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va pas du rire
charlie chuck dès que le rire était le
chemin le plus direct entre deux
personnes
quand deux personnes riz de la même
chose c'est qu'elle se comprennent
qu'elles se comprennent au delà des mots
car le dès qu'on ne rit pas tous des
mêmes choses et que le fait de partager
le même humour en dit peut-être
davantage sur nos affinités que delon
parole
alors il y à cette fameuse question vous
savez peut-on rire de tout
oui on peut rire de tout
évidemment qu'on peut rire de tout
mais est ce que cette question a
vraiment du sens
parce que demander si on peut rire de
tout c'est faire du rire une question
morale
c'est faire du rire une question de
droit
on n'a pas de adrien de si on n'a pas le
droit de rire de ça on n'a pas le droit
de rire du racisme de rire de la
souffrance de rire de l'oppression
mais on ne se demande jamais si on a le
droit de pleurer de telle ou telle chose
or rire ou pleurer
ce sont les deux faces de la même pièce
parce que dans les deux cas il s'agit
d'une réaction émotionnelle
or une émotion ça ne se commande pas
ça ne se décrète pas
une émotion c'est un de la morale
quand vous riez ou quand vous pleurez
vous ne vous posez pas la question de
savoir si c'est bien ou mal
ou alors si vous le faites c'est
toujours après coup
jamais avant
le rire ne se contrôle pas
il ne se prémédite pas
et donc faire du rire une question
morale c'est viser à côté de la cible
s'est passé à côté de la vraie question
qui est pourquoi aurions-nous
autrement dit qu exprimons-nous par le
rire
de quoi le rire est il le symptôme
on sait que le rire est un phénomène
universel
tous les êtres humains prix
il ne rit pas tous des mêmes choses mais
il rit tous de certaines choses
et donc comprendre la signification du
rire c'est comprendre que le rire est
d'abord un phénomène physiologique
et si le rire est un phénomène
physiologique ça signifie qu'il a une
fonction
et c'est d'abord sous cet angle là qu'il
faut analyser la signification du rire
sous l'angle de la fonction
or quelle est la fonction du rire sa
fonction physiologique
c'est d'évacuer une tension
aussi paradoxal que cela puisse paraître
la fonction du rire ces expulsés une
tension
attention au sens quasi mécanique
comme lorsqu'on tire sur un élastique
jusqu'au moment où la tension est
maximale et que l'élastique lâche
le rire est un relâchement
et si le rire et le relâchement d'une
tension ça veut dire que l'origine du
rire et peut-être à l'opposé de ce que
le rire produits
en clair l'origine du rire
ce n'est pas la joie
la joie ne fait pas rire
la joie est la conséquence du rire qui
lui même est une réaction à quelque
chose qui n'est pas joyeux
l'origine du rire c'est une tension à
laquelle le rire est une réponse
prenons un exemple
vous marchez la rue vous voyez un homme
qui marche devant vous et tout à coup
cet homme glisse et se casse la figure
bon ben ça c'est drôle
pourquoi c'est drôle c'est drôle parce
que premièrement vous ne vous y
attendiez pas donc le rire se compose
d'abord d'un élément de surprise
et parce que deuxièmement une chute ça
renvoie instinctivement un danger
la chute c'est la perte de contrôle de
notre corps une perte de contrôle qui
peut aboutir sinon à la mort du moins à
la blessure
donc il n'y a rien de drôle a priori
dans le fait d'assister à une chute
mais justement ce qui provoque le rire
c'est le fait de savoir que la personne
ne s'est finalement pas blessé
on rit quand on comprend que la personne
qui est tombée est indemne
et par le rire on expulse l'attention on
expulse la peur qui avait été provoqué
par la chute comme pour dire ouf
tout va bien
le rire est un sou j'm'en
voir quelqu'un tombait du huitième étage
et s'écraser sur le trottoir ça ne fait
rire personne
ou alors il faut consulter
donc le rire c'est le point de rencontre
entre la tension la tension instinctive
liés au danger il ya la peur que la
personne se soit blessé et la prise de
conscience soudaine que la personne ne
s'est finalement pas blessé
donc l'origine du rire n'est pas la
chute
c'est la chute accompagné de la
conscience de la non gravité de la chute
et c'est ce duo tension relâchement
cette conjonction de deux émotions
antagonistes qui se succèdent si
rapidement qu'elle se superposent qui
permet de comprendre la fonction
physiologique du rire
vous voyez que vu sous cet angle le rire
n'est pas du tout l'expression de la
méchanceté ou du sadisme
le rire est au contraire l'expression
d'un soulagement
c'est l'expression de l'évacuation d'un
stress au même titre que la
transpiration ou l'accélération du
rythme cardiaque
et je disais tout à l'heure que le fait
de rire et le fait de pleurer
constituaient les deux faces de la même
pièce on peut le vérifier
après un stress violents après une
inquiétude violente il pourra vous
arriver de verser des larmes de
soulagement
votre enfant disparaît vous paniquez
votre corps est inondée d'adrénaline
l'adrénaline dont la fonction est
justement de vous faire supporter le
stress
est dès lors que vous retrouvez votre
enfant votre corps cesse brutalement de
produire de l'adrénaline et tout votre
corps se relâche
vous allez pleurer parce que votre corps
aura accumulé tellement d'adrénaline
qu'il vous faudra évacuer la pression
d'une manière ou d'une autre
quand le corps réagit
c'est toujours une réponse
parce que le corps est gouvernée par un
principe qu'on appelle l'homéostasie
l'homéostasie celle équilibre
physiologique
c'est la stabilisation physiologique et
c'est ce qui fait de votre corps va
réagir à une situation pour pouvoir la
supporter
et bien la fonction du rire c'est la
stabilisation émotionnel
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait qu'il est
très difficile de se retenir de rire
comme il est difficile de se retenir de
tousser ou d'éternuer
parce que ça relève d'un réflexe
corporelle
se retenir de rire s'est obstrué un
mécanisme physique nécessaire à la
stabilisation
et c'est ce qui fait qu'en général plus
on se retient de rire
plus on a envie de rire
mais maintenant st il faut aller plus
loin
il faut aller plus loin parce que il
arrive parfois que nous rions sans que
ce soit lié à l'évacuation d'une tension
rires de quelqu'un qui tombe par terre
c'est une chose mais dans la vie de tous
les jours on rit de bien d'autres choses
qui n'ont pas de rapport avec ce genre
de situation
eh bien on va voir qu'on fait si il y à
un rapport et pour le comprendre il va
falloir tueur et sur la question de
l'humour
l'humour c'est l'art de provoquer le
rire
faire de l'humour s'est créé des
situations le plus souvent par les mots
qui vont reproduire par la pensée ce jeu
de tension relâchement
alors dit comme ça ça peut paraître un
peu abstrait parce qu'on se dit qu'entre
quelqu'un qui tombe par terre est ce
qu'on appelle faire de l'humour on ne se
situe pas du tout sur le même plan
et bien latence on parle dans l'humour
c'est l'attention issus du décalage
entre ce qui est dit ou la manière dont
s'est dit et ce qu'on considère comme
étant la normalité
le rire se nourrit de la normalité elle
apostrophe
il se nourrit de l'inattendu de
l'incongru de l'excès faut
il se nourrit de tout ce qui sort des
clous
c'est l'effet de surprise dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
et donc quand on va assister à une scène
incongrue ou quand quelqu'un va nous
raconter quelque chose d'incongru
d'incongru c'est-à-dire de contraire aux
conventions de contraire aux usages en
vigueur
de contraire à la normalité
et que cette incongruité ne présente pas
de danger pour notre vie ou pour la vie
d'un tiers on va en rire
on va en rire parce que là encore il y
aura eu tension
l'incongruité
et évacuation de cette tension par la
conscience qu'une telle incongruité ne
constitue pas une menace envers la vie
ou envers l'ordre social
l'absurde nous fait rire parce que
l'absurde renverse la normalité
l'absurde renverse qui est attendue sans
que ce renversement ne constitue un
danger
un jeu de mots nous fait rire parce
qu'un jeu de mots renverse le sens d'un
propos varin sens qu'il a encore ses
cartes de ce qui était attendu
donc les sens du rire c'est le décalage
c'est la déviance
déviance au sens littéral c'est à dire
au sens de détournement
et donc le rire provient du relâchement
de cette tension issu du détournement
issus du décalage entre la normalité et
ce qui surgit comme anormale étant
entendu que l'attention dont on parle
ici ce n'est pas une tension liée à un
danger physique
c'est une tension liée un danger
symbolique
un jeu de mots ne véhiculent aucun
danger physique
une blague ne véhiculent aucun danger
physique
mais la perspective d'un monde dans
lequel cette blague serait la normalité
créé une tension avec notre
représentation et notre expérience de la
normalité
d'ailleurs si les blagues sexuelles nous
font rire c'est parce que l'évocation de
la sexualité en public génère une
tension
une tension liée au fait que la
sexualité est quelque chose de
normalement réservée à la sphère de
l'intimité
nous sommes des animaux sociaux
nous ne copule ont pas en public la
sexualité est donc frappé du sceau du
tabou social
et faire une blague grivoise c'est
introduire du tabou dans l'espace de la
socialité
on rit parce qu'on transgresse
symboliquement un interdit sociale
donc il ya bien une tension une tension
liée à l'interdît liés aux tabous suivi
d'une évacuation de la tension par le
rire du fait que la tension est jugé
sans danger
donc on ne parle pas d'une tension liée
à un danger physique comme dans le cas
de la chute on parle d'une tension
symbolique et mentale issue d'un
décalage entre ce qui est dit et les
conventions sociales
quand les enfants s'amusent à dire des
grossièretés ça les fait rire justement
parce qu'ils prennent conscience du
caractère interdit et socialement à bout
de certaines paroles
et donc le simple fait de transgresser
ce qui l'ont identifié comme étant un
tabou social va suffire à les faire rire
les enfants ne sont pas idiots
ils sentent bien quand certains mots
créent un malaise
quand certains mots n'ont pas leur place
et ils vont en jouer c'est à dire ils
vont jouer avec la tension entre ce qui
se dit et ce qui ne se dit pas entre le
respect des règles sociales et la
transgression de ces règles sociales
parce que pour eux aussi le rire naît de
cette tension
tout à l'heure on évoquait le fait de
rire du racisme de la souffrance ou de
l'oppression
ce qu'on appelle communément l'humour
noir
ce qui fait rire dans l'humour noir
ce n'est pas le propos qui est tenu
c'est la tension entre le propos tenus
et les conventions sociales qui prohibe
un tel propos
c'est la conscience qu'une limite est
franchie et cette conscience va produire
un choc elle va produire un conflit que
le rire aura pour fonction d'évacuer
et c'est parce qu'on aura identifié une
attention bienveillante de la part de
celui qui fait la blague qu'on pourra en
rire
on ne rit pas parce que quelqu'un tient
des propos offensants
on rit à cause de la tension entre un
propos offensants c'est à dire un propos
qui se heurte à la normalité et la
conscience que ce propos n'est pas tenue
sérieusement
c'est ça qui nous fait rire
l'expérience du choc sans danger
et dès lors qu'on identifie une
intention malveillante derrière le
propos celui ci cessent d'être drôle
et donc on en revient à ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure avec l'exemple de celui
qui tombe par terre la personne qui
tombe par terre on ne rit pas parce
qu'elle s'est fait mal on rit parce
qu'on sait qu'elle ne s'est pas fait mal
mais que l'espace d'un instant une
tension s'est formé
et que cette tension doit trouver un
moyen de s'échapper dès lors qu il se
confirme que la chute est sans gravité
et bien la même façon l'humour noir nous
fait rire parce que l'humour noir créé
une tension et que le rire permet
d'évacuer cette tension
dès lors que le propos n'est pas motivée
par le désir de blessés
c'est ce qu'on appelle la catharsis
le rire comme moyen de purgation
bon mais c'est dire ah mais à la base on
était quand même censé parler du rire
chez bergson
or là on a eu droit un laïus d'un quart
d'heure sur le rire mais toujours pas de
bergson
et bien on y arrive
la première chose à dire c'est que
bergson ne serait sans doute pas
d'accord avec ce que j'ai dit jusqu'à
présent
pourquoi parce que pour berck sonne le
rire n'est pas simplement une réaction
physiologique
le rire n'est pas seulement le
relâchement d'une tension
pour berck sonne le rire est un chat
ciment
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
on l'a vu tout rang le rire est une
réaction à l'inattendu
nous vivons en société la société
fonctionne sur des règles sur des
conventions
et ne pas respecter ces conventions
c'est mettre en péril les conditions de
la coexistence
quand le fait de transgresser ces
conventions ne constitue pas une menace
sérieuse pour la vie en société on peut
en rire
mais ce que nous dit bergson c'est que
par le rire nous n'exprimons pas le
relâchement d'une tension
nous stigmatisons celui qui s'écartent
des règles
le rire stigmatise
parce que le rire est comme un doigt
pointé vers celui qui n'obéit pas à la
norme
est donc probable sonne le rire a
d'abord signification sociale
il a une fonction sociales cels
d'exclure symboliquement
celui dont le comportement n'est pas
adéquat aux exigences de la vie sociale
est ce que ça veut dire que pour
personne le rire est forcément moqueur
et bien oui le rire est forcément
moqueur
le rire est forcément cruel
on disait alors que l'humour noir
n'était pas motivée par la cruauté
qu'ils étaient même tout à fait
compatible avec la bienveillance et bien
selon bergson ce n'est pas le cas
selon personnes le rire a toujours
quelque chose de cruel parce qu'il se
fait toujours au détriment d'un bouc
émissaire
on pense immédiatement aux moqueries
dans la cour d'école
au groupe d'enfants qui se liguent
contre un autre parce qu'il est
différent
on va se moquer du binoclard va se
moquer du gros du rouquin on va se
moquer de tous ceux qui s'écartent un
tant soit peu de la norme
donc le rire a non seulement une
fonction stigmatisante mais aussi une
fonction unificatrice
le groupe uni par le rire xx e ligue et
il se liguent d'autant plus facilement
qui peut exclure tout ce qui diffère de
la norme du groupe
le rire est l'agent du conformisme
social
un enfant qui by des moqueries un enfant
dont on rit c'est un enfant auquel on
envoie un message qui est
tu ne fais pas partie du groupe
tu es mise au banc
et aussi longtemps que tu t'écartes eu
ras de la norme de la moyenne
tu sera condamné à l' isolement social
les gens qui se moquent sont très
conformiste
le moindre petit écart avec la norme la
moindre petite originalité
et vous sautent dessus
parce que nous dit bergson la société se
venge des libertés comprend avec elle
s'écarter de la norme c'est prendre une
liberté avec l'ordre social
et prendre une liberté avec l'ordre
social c'est menacer l'ordre social
le rire est armes
donc quand on dit que le rire est
subversif back soon répond qu'au
contraire le rire et anti subversif
le rire stigmatise la subversion le rire
corrige les écarts par l'humiliation de
celui qui en est l'objet
l'enfant dont on rit comprend bien que
le rire qu'il suscite n'a rien de
bienveillant
d'ailleurs c'est ça que le meilleur
moyen de faire cesser les moqueries sur
soi c'est d'en rire
si on rit soi même des moqueries qui
nous sont adressées
elles perdent leur caractère humiliant
et si la moquerie perd son caractère
humiliant elle n'a plus d'intérêt
c'est ça que nous dit bergson
rire est un correctif social
mais il ya chez une idée supplémentaire
une idée un peu plus subtil un peu moins
intuitive que j'aimerais vous exposez
maintenant parce que c'est cette idée
qui est vraiment la pièce maîtresse de
sa conception philosophique du rire
l'idée de personne c'est que le rire est
avant tout une réaction à l'intrusion du
mécanique dans le vivant
alors là il va falloir expliquer
personnes s'intéressent
même du vivant
et il remarque que le vivant se
caractérise par la fluidité par la
souplesse
là où le mécanique se caractérise au
contraire par la raideur
par le mouvement saccadé
entre un être humain est un robot il n'y
a pas simplement une différence
d'apparence
il y a une différence de vie corporelle
d'intériorité corporelle
ce qui fait qu'on peut différencier un
être humain d'un robot humanoïde
ce sont toutes ces petites nuances
indicible qui font que l'être humain est
un être infiniment complexe
le pétillement du regard
les micro expressions du visage
les aspérités de la peau tout ça c'est
le propre de l'humain
l'être humain est un nuancier en
mouvement
et c'est cette infinie complexité de
l'humain et du vivant en général
qui fait qu on percevra toujours qu'on
sentira toujours la différence entre de
l'humain et du mécanique
est bien ce que nous dit bergson c'est
que le rire intervient quand on perçoit
dans le comportement d'un humain quelque
chose de l'ordre du mécanique
on va prendre un exemple que bergson
utilise lui même qui est le comique de
répétition
le comique de répétition au théâtre
c'est quand un personnage répète à
plusieurs reprises une même parole ou un
même geste
donc ce qui provoque le rire dans le
comique de répétition
ce n'est pas chaque parole où chaque
geste pris isolément
c'est la récurrence de cette parole ou
de ce geste à la manière d'un automate
et donc quand un personnage répète la
même parole ou le même geste
c'est comme s'il n'était plus totalement
un être humain
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire dès
lors que votre comportement obéit à un
schéma mécanique dès lors que votre
comportement devient prévisible
vous devenez un personnage
et en devenant un personnage vous
devenez comique
remarquez comme nous rions souvent des
manies des gens de notre entourage
de leurs manies de langage de leurs
manies de comportement c'est à dire de
leur récurrence
une manie c'est un mouvement mécanique
et un mouvement mécanique tout dix
personnes c'est un mouvement sans la vie
c'est un mouvement dont pour ainsi dire
la vie s'est absenté
donc à chaque fois que nous exécutons
l'une de nos manies à chaque fois que
nous remplissons l'imprévisibilité de
notre prochaine action de l'automaticité
de notre manie
nous devenons le personnage de notre
manie et ce faisant nous devenons un
objet de rire
ce qui suit le rire nous dit bergson ce
n'est pas ce que nous disons ou ce que
nous faisons
c'est le caractère mécanique c'est à
dire dépourvu de vie de ce que nous
disons ou de ce que nous faisons
et le rire intervient là encore comme
une punition
on punit par le rire celui qui a
momentanément
tourner le dos à la vie en adoptant un
comportement mécanique
on a tous déjà vécu cette situation où
on pose une question à un ami et il nous
répond quelque chose qui n'a rien à voir
avec la question posée
c'était bien tes vacances
non juste un verre d'eau
ok mais sinon tes vacances
alors oui l'explication la plus
fréquente c'est que notre ami a tout
simplement mal compris ce qu'on lui a
dit
mais le fait est que quand il nous
répond ça l'impression qu'on a c'est
qu'on n'a pas affaire à un être humain
connectés
connecter à nos paroles connectés au
monde
connecté à la vie
on a sion d'une déconnexion avec la vie
ce qu'on appelle une absence
et bien l'absence c'est l'absence de vie
c'est la sortie de la vie
et par le rire nous signalons en même
temps que nous sanctionnons cette sortie
momentanée de la vie
c'est ce que bergson appelle la
distraction
la distraction provoque le rire parce
que la distraction va à l'encontre d'une
caractéristique essentielle de la vie
qui est la tension
par le rire nous corrigeons
l'inattention de l'autre à la vie
et nous leur amenons de force dans le
champ de l'interaction humaine
robertson si le rire est une sanction
c'est parce qu'il est un double rappel à
l'ordre
un rappel à l'ordre social
qui condamne l'excentricité qui condamne
l'originalité
le manquement aux conventions
et un rappel à l'ordre vital
qui condamne la distraction
qui condamne l'inattention
et qui se manifeste à chaque fois que tu
mécanique
s'immisce dans du vivant
je cite
le mécanisme aides que nous surprenons
de temps à autre comme un intrus dans la
vie vante continuité des choses humaines
a pour nous un intérêt tout particulier
parce qu'il est comme une distraction de
la vie c'est des événements pouvaient
être sans cesse attentifs à leur propre
cour il n'y aurait pas de coïncidence
pas de rencontre pas de série circulaire
tout se déroulerait en avant et
progresserait toujours et si les hommes
étaient toujours attentif à la vie sinon
reprenions constamment contact avec
autrui et aussi avec nous même jamais
rien ne paraîtraient se produire en nous
par ressort ou ficelles le comique et ce
côté de la personne par lequel elle
ressemble à une chose
cet aspect des événements humains qui
imite par sa raideur d'un genre tout
particulier le mécanisme pur et simple
l'automatisme enfin le mouvement sans la
vie
il exprime donc une imperfection
individuelle ou collective qui appelle
la correction immédiate le rire est
cette correction même le rire est
incertain geste social qui souligne
réprime une certaine distraction
spéciale des hommes et des événements
le rire est avant tout une correction
fait pour humilier il doit donner à la
personne qui en est l'objet une
impression pénible
la société se vengent par lui des
libertés qu'on a prise avec elle il
n'atteindrait pas son but s'il portait
la marque de la sympathie et de la bonté
le rire chatte si certains défauts à peu
près comme la maladie chatte si certains
excès frappant des innocents épargnants
des coupables visant à un résultat
général et ne pouvant faire à chaque cas
individuel l'honneur de l'examiner
séparément en ce sens le rire ne peut
pas être absolument juste répétons qu'il
ne doit pas non plus être bon il a pour
fonction d'intimider en humiliant il n'y
réussirais pas si la nature n'avait
laissé à cet effet dans les meilleurs
d'entre les hommes un petit fond de
méchanceté ou tout au moins de malice
peut-être faudra-t-il mieux que nous
n'approfondissent y ont pas trop ce
point nous nous trouverions rien de très
flatteur pour nous
s'il est vrai que le rire s'accompagne
nécessairement d'une part de cruauté
toute la question est de savoir si nous
est possible de
réprimer cette cruauté
cette cruauté qui menace à chaque
instant la coexistence avec nos
semblables
qui menace à chaque instant
l'ordre social
mais kim en croire bergson
nous poussent également
achats c'est tout ce qui ne se conforme
pas à ce même ordre social
quand parler de l'un sociable
sociabilité de l'être humain
de ce double penchons à vouloir faire
société
et à vouloir détruire
ce qui fait société
freud ne disait pas autre chose
quand il décrivait le conflit intérieur
des hommes entre le ça et le surmoi
entre le pôle pulsionnel diriger vers la
destruction
et le pôle rationnelle
diriger vers l'ordre
de ce point de vue larmes le rire est
peu être le trait d'union entre notre
animalité et notre humanité
le visage humain de la cruauté
sans lequel nous serions peut-être plus
bienveillants plus compatissant
mais sans lequel nous serions peut-être
aussi
de purs sauvage
nous sommes des animaux capables de rire
comme pour mieux rendre notre cruauté
vivable
supportable
comme pour mieux rendre notre conditions
supportables
car s'il confronté à la souffrance
à l'injustice
au désespoir
il et consolant de savoir qu'il reste au
moins cette chance à l'homme
de pouvoir en rire
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]